I have had to do what I have least wanted to do and that is to take them in.
His quality is is for horrible based cancers.
So his quality is a drug daily medication for horrible based,
horrible positive or too negative breast cancer.
What can I take to support my body side effects through this?
I don't want to be on the forever as they expect.
I will go back to other methods after my numbers get under control.
Well, if you're on a daily chemotype pill, that's affecting your body,
whether it be you're doing immunotherapy or you're doing IV chemotherapy, etc.
You want to detoxify it and the negative effects of that.
You're not going to do something that's going to key late the drug.
If you're going to take the drug, you want it to work.
So you're really going to have to just support your body every way you know how to do it.
You eat right, you try to take care of yourself, you try to support your liver detox pathways,
you work on your parasympathetic control, you do coffee,
you're running the right, you're doing everything you need,
you know you need to do, you know is the right thing to do.
And then unfortunately, you have to treat the core amenities when they come up.
It's just like, what can I do to prevent all my side effects of chemotherapy?
There's nothing you could do to prevent all the side effects of chemotherapy.
You have to deal with them as they come up.
You don't know if you're going to have any side effects of chemotherapy.
First of all, you do everything you know to do, which is right.
And then you have to deal with things when they come up.
There's nothing else you can do.
It's like you have questions, some people have had questions.
I'm on immunotherapy and I'm afraid it's going to cause autoimmune disease.
Can I help prevent that?
Not really though, you have to just treat it when it comes out.
There's nothing else you could do.
So I wish there was just a magic way that you didn't have any side effects of different things,
but these are drugs that affect our body and you just do the best you can.
And you got to trust God for the difference.
This is where faith comes in.
You're putting your faith in Jesus Christ.
You're not putting your faith in things.
So properly applied faith is really important.